quels sont vos perspectives je pense
qu'il y a vraiment aucun débouché pour
les artistes en général
[Musique]
vous respectez toutes les traditions
c'est vraiment l'opinion que le grand
public se fait des Beaux-Arts
folklore dans l'école et vous connaissez
déjà la fête traditionnelle du rouge 20
où il y a les chars qui les filent dans
tous les quartiers il y a également le
bal des katzar qui est bien connu du
monde entier il y a aussi le gala de
l'école qui est beaucoup plus chic mais
que quand même une fête et il y a
évidemment toutes les fanfares des
ateliers donc vous avez un certain
nombre d'exemples ici enfin c'est tout
de même l'école c'est pas uniquement des
festivités
interstellaire membre de l'Institut
peintre fresquiste que nous allons
d'ailleurs retrouver tout de suite dans
l'ancien hôtel de bouillon auprès de
jardin romantique
Monsieur le Directeur combien y a-t-il
d'élèves dans votre maison numéro 3000
qui serait parti
environ
2300 architectes 430
et vous pouvez loger tous ces gens dans
votre école ce problème d'effectif n'est
pas pour vous un problème justement
c'est un très grand problème il était
entre beaucoup plus tard il y a une
dizaine d'années mais malgré les
constructions que nous avons vérifié
depuis 10 ans comme je vous dis nous
sommes encore
[Musique]
enseignement que vous dispensez et
beaucoup plus un dialogue entre vous et
vos élèves
parce que je ne sais même pas s'il y a
un enseignement proprement dit il peut y
avoir entre des êtres
au fond de la même discipline un
dialogue fructueux dans la mesure où je
m'efforce plus âgé que de les aider à se
trouver eux-mêmes ou en tout cas à se
définir pour commencer et alors à ce
moment-là je pense que mon intervention
peut-être dans une certaine mesure utile
mademoiselle nous avons déjà posé dans
un autre atelier les questions
concernant le débouché des peintres
quelles sont vos perspectives je pense
qu'il
y a débouchés pour les artistes en
général même le prix des Beaux-Arts le
prix de Rome attribué comme dans le
passé ne donne absolument plus qu'est-ce
que ça pouvait donner dans l'avenir une
rémunération assurée l'avenir à se
perdre jusqu'à la fin de ces jours alors
dans Ça c'est complètement le message je
crois que c'est vrai ce que vous dites
j'ai autant que je me rappelle les les
élèves qui obtenaient le prix de Rome
autrefois était assuré je ne dis pas
jusqu'à la fin de leur vie mais pendant
un long temps
de la facilité sociale qui correspondait
à leur diplôme oui c'est ça
donc voilà professeur j'avais fait cette
toile
cette expression je l'ai fait avant de
celle-ci et maintenant mon problème
c'est justement de trouver une forme que
j'ai
éliminé presque la couleur
vous avez vu qu'au centre l'école de
Beaux-Arts il y a d'une part
l'architecture et d'autre part ce que
l'on appelle traditionnellement les
beaux-arts c'est-à-dire la sculpture la
peinture la gravure le problème se pose
de savoir si l'architecture d'une part
et d'autre part les beaux-arts sont
faits pour vivre ensemble l'architecture
en effet des bouches sur l'utilisation
et d'autre part elle est de toute
évidence matière d'enseignement les
beaux-arts architectes sculptures et
peinture sont des arts de luxe à propos
desquels on peut se demander s'il y a un
enseignement possible vous avez ici par
exemple une très grande presse qui élève
de Mademoiselle Huro et qu'elle a
terminé qui est une étude dans les
blancs et les noirs qui est une des
choses les plus difficiles à en fresque
à cause de la difficulté qu'on a de
fixer les blancs à leur juste valeur et
vous avez ici des élèves d'étrangers qui
travaillent enfin je ne suis briote qui
est très longtemps à l'école et qui fait
une presse très grande une fresque de 16
mètres avec une grande bataille je
regrette de ne pas pouvoir vous en
montrer plus pour le moment il y a une
question qui nous intéresse dans toutes
les disciplines de cette maison c'est de
savoir quel déboucher on les élèves à
leur sortie de l'école
je crois que c'est un peu
le mystère
l'inconnu mais enfin on a l'espoir de
s'en sortir façon si on est là c'est
bien pour s'en sortir ça veut dire il
reste quoi
et l'opinion de tous les élèves de cet
atelier est la même
[Musique]
c'est pas une ancienne
non mais c'est peut-être le moment de
dire le mot de Simon justement qui
disait faut rentrer en sculpture comme
on rentre en religion
je trouvais que les contacts sont trop
lâches
ils sont très très distants on peut dire
à quelques concours on fait en commun et
dans lequel la personnalité de chacun
n'est pas tellement affirmé quoi
je pense que pour nous c'est un problème
bien sûr le problème de la de la
collaboration avec les architectes avec
les entrepreneurs les sculpteurs les
peintres et les peintres
mais comme je vous dis nous
souhaiterions avoir personnellement un
enseignement
qui nous amène à des
envisager les problèmes de l'avenir avec
plus de
personnalité plus affirmée somme toute
vous seriez assez d'accord avec les
élèves sculpteurs et peintre quand la
synthèse qui doit se faire au sein de
l'école autour de l'architecture sans
aucun doute
[Musique]